[FOREIGN] That is a well-known Swahili
proverb that means unity is strength,
division is weakness.
At first glance I may not look like it,
but I'm from Kenya and
I've always been a very proud Kenyan.
I represented the country for over ten
years as an international swimmer.
And was given the biggest honor of my life
when I was chosen to carry the Kenyan
flag into the opening ceremony of
the London 2012 Olympic Games.
My swimming career took
me all over the world and
within that, many parts of Africa.
I visited cities from Cape Town to
Casablanca, from Dakar to Dar es Salaam.
And I always felt incredibly at
home in all of these cities.
As I was travelling around Africa and
competing, I was fiercely competitive.
And I wanted to do everything I could
to get my hand on the wall first and
bring a medal back home to Kenya.
But at the same time, I formed deep
friendships with many of the swimmers I
was up against from just about every one
of the 55 nations recognized
by the African union.
And I'm sure the implications of these
experiences were seeded back then and
begun to germinate.
But it's only over the last year that I've
begun to understand their deeper meaning.
I now believe that it will be better for
Kenya, Africa, and
the world if Africa were
to become more united.
The more united Africa will
mean a more prosperous Africa.
And we'll finally complete the Africa
rising narrative that is being told
the world over.
And in these times of
rising nationalism and
isolationism in different pockets
of the world, a more united Africa
could just be the inspiration the world
needs for greater global unity.
When I arrived at Stanford in 2016, one of
the first things I did was interview for
position on the leadership team for
the 10th annual African Business
Conference held here on campus.
I was part of the group of students
from all over Africa, not only that,
all over the world.
And we worked hard to
try to put on the most
successful African Business Conference
we'd ever had here in GSB.
Pulled a lot of all nighters and we
ended up putting on one of the most well
attended student organized conferences
in the history of the GSB.
I was very proud.
We were all very proud
about what we had achieved.
And as I thought about it, again the
implications, they didn't really hit me.
I'm at Stanford, of course I'm going to be
in part of a high performing team, right?
>> [LAUGH]
>> So conference experience done,
went back to work.
Out of that experience at the conference
though, I started an interview channel.
And sat down with some of my classmates,
run some interviews.
And many of them are actually
in the audience today.
And out of that experience I
got invited to go and cover
the silicon valley African film festival
that is held every year here in San Jose.
At the festival, I was part of a group
of people, again from all over Africa,
from all over the world in
fact united in celebrating
the unique cultures of different
countries of the continent.
But it really felt that we're all coming
together with one voice in celebration.
And as I was running around the conference
trying to source interviews for
the red carpet, I bumped into this
one man called Ayouba Karamoko.
As I started questioning him, I started
to learn a little bit about him and
that he's a musician,
martial artist, teacher, and
I'm asking where he's from and
he says, I'm from Africa.
I said, yeah, most people here are,
can you be a little more specific?
>> [LAUGH]
>> So he grudgingly tells me he's from
the Ivory Coast.
And we continue interview and
I'm thinking, okay,
I'm not sure why he's being so
grudging about this.
And I asked him what brings
him to the film festival?
And he talks about coming to support the
African filmmakers that were there, but
also that he's releasing a new album.
The name of the album,
The United States of Africa,
Act 1, the awakening.
And looking back that spoke to me
a lot of what was going on for
me, but I was still resistant,
I was like big idea, yes.
But realistic, not so sure.
Came back to Standford got back to work.
And then I heard that one of my
heroes was coming to Silicon Valley.
And not just to Silicon Valley,
he'd be coming right here to the GSB to
speak on the very stage
I'm standing on right now.
His name is Strive Masiyiwa.
For those who don't know,
he's one of Africa's great businessmen.
He's built a telecom business that spans
the whole continent connecting people,
and he started it with just $500.
He was persecuted under Mugabe's
regime in Zimbabwe, and
against all odds,
has built something quite incredible.
And I was part of 20 students that
were actually invited to come and
have lunch with him after he spoke.
And so we all assembled in Sewell
Boardroom in Bass Library to wait for
him to enter the room.
And as we're lining up,
he enters the room and I put out my
hand to greet him as one always does.
And I instinctively say,
sir, it's great to meet you.
My name is Jason, I'm from Kenya.
And he doesn't say anything.
So we're there, holding hands,
I'm clasping his.
And he turns to the rest
of the students assembled.
And he says,
I want you to introduce yourself, but
I want you to say you're from Africa.
And then tell me your town or
city of origin.
So, I try again.
My name is Jason.
I'm from Africa, in the city of Nairobi.
And now the synopsis in my head
were firing out of control,
because I do has been a little of,
I'd say offended,
when people abroad would refer to
Africa as if it were one country.
And he was Strive Masiyiwa,
one of my heroesm telling me not to
vilify that kind of thinking,
but to in fact encourage it.
And the challenge he laid
out to us as future business
leaders in Africa was clear.
In order to drive a more
progressive development agenda,
we have to become more united.
As a complete market,
Africa is 1.2 billion people,
$4.4 trillion combined economy,
youngest population in the world
that is expected to double by 2050.
He said this population growth
could be a blessing or a curse and
it's incumbent on us to
make sure it's a blessing.
To do that we need to become more united.
Some more goods are used internally.
Increased trade between the thriving
cities that I've been so
lucky to visit and we have to form teams,
like I was a part of at the business
conference to lead organizations that can
provide the jobs that we'll be needing.
And not to say there's not going to
be a lot of challenges along the way.
This is a difficult proposition.
But it doesn't mean it's not
something we should strive for.
I mean,
it's oftentimes that the things most worth
doing in life are the most difficult.
Since I last gave this talk,
six weeks ago, there have been
some developments and
44 African nations have now signed out
an agreement to create
the African Continental Free Trade Area.
It's a first step and
the momentum is there,
but we must continue to accelerate it
to get to a United States of Africa.
[FOREIGN] It is easier to cross the ocean,
if we're all swimming together.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]